so you said this year you've been
walking a lot he'd been writing right
and that's it you must have been doing
other things yeah I mean work wise I
mean yeah I mean after I did the film
heuk yeah and then I tried the whole the
whole acting thing and you know I'm
still doing it but I kind of needed to
take time for I think I just burned out
but you must have got from that movie
you must have got a lot like auditions a
lot of bunch yeah yeah and did you land
anything now let's just call back since
it so oh that's so disheartening it's
okay like I really don't give a [ __ ]
okay I thought I would care a little bit
more so the first audition I went to I
think I mentioned that I was devastated
but you couldn't get scabbed over after
that so after a while I would go in and
I'm like mmm it was pretty terrible you
just kind of just it is what it is and I
think like what I found out to some of
the best actors they just suck at
auditioning yeah they're auditioning
skills aren't great you know but they're
great actors and so I just I mean I was
I kind of figure out what everybody I've
never been able to do it and I've talked
about it before I know I want to get
into it now but like I've just never
been able to figure that out that's the
one question I get so nervous for some
reason that it's just not what I would
do normally you know I'm not I'm the
opposite because I don't get congregate
I get angry because I kind of go to the
room and I'm like who the [ __ ] are you
you know I mean like how do you how do
you get the judge whether I get to be at
the bar you a good actor like what the
[ __ ] I don't look it I felt like maybe
the aggressiveness my like a comedy ride
coming I'm like let's [ __ ] get this
over with
alright oh wow that's your energy in
there no I'm actually very yeah
but in my mind yeah yeah yeah I do a
thing where I'm like um you know like I
don't know what I'm doing and I'm just
I'm shy when I walk into a room even
though they clearly know who you are
they don't do it you Bobby Lee everybody
knows no I'm gonna tell you why people
don't know who I am I tell you why I
know yeah well we're at that Korean
barbecue bright by the Brahe and profit
yeah right they treated me like [ __ ]
what Korean guy yeah you don't speak
Korean that's why yeah but if you knew
who I was and you treat me better but he
was like yeah no I was too afraid to ask
for more kimchi
you know what he did I go uh what's our
Jessica just gonna ask for more kimchi I
think why don't you do it
host doesn't go above and beyond or
recognizes him he thinks that it's bad
service but the guy actually was really
good they were used to being a hot chick
that's why yeah that's the hot chick
syndrome yes you stop stop Emmett I'm
okay
wasn't he nice yeah no it's this is
here's what it is is that oh can you get
some rice oh yeah
he gets it comes back and you go can we
get some more kimchi as soon as he comes
back at the riot I can sense in his head
beyond his eyes there's a look well you
say that when you know min when you ask
for the [ __ ] rice why didn't you
because I forgot my point though he says
that when I go into a restaurant I want
them to go yeah you can ask whatever you
want as many times as you but you got to
be responsible when you're ordering so
you can't be like can I get the sesame
oil and then Co he comes back oh can I
also get the salt and then like five
other things afterwards yeah I can do
whatever I want you know why cuz I'm a
hot chick all right I ain't got no [ __ ]
I got no [ __ ] I'm a man okay and I'm
not in there like a hot chick I'm in
there with oh it's a human being just
trying to get my [ __ ] rice you like
you good man yeah yeah
I never heard anybody say puss like yeah
Thank You Nick thank you up in the South
yeah I've done my work
[Music]